[Música]
el presidente Reyes hay perdón ganó la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en Turquía la Comisión
Nacional electoral ratificó la victoria
y el mandatario aseguró que la única
ganadora de la jornada es la democracia
turca a su vez el Derrotado opositor que
mal philipsaroglu Indicó que fueron las
elecciones más injustas en años
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden anunció que se alcanzó un acuerdo
bipartidista sobre el aumento en el
techo de la deuda que tendrá que ser
votado por el congreso el mandatario
instó a los legisladores a probarlo para
sacar de la mesa la posibilidad del
impago
miles de mexicanos marcharon para
defender el papel de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia y de sus integrantes según los
ciudadanos el gobierno está hostigando
al máximo tribunal tras las decisiones
en contra de la llamada cuarta
transformación que impulsa el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador Tenemos
reporte
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en France 24 soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en Turquía porque
reviepta y perdón continuará siendo
presidente durante al menos cinco años
más la comisión electoral ratificó la
victoria del mandatario y esto tras
conocerse los resultados de la jornada
en la que la oposición denunció
irregularidades erdogan abogó por la
unidad y afirmó que el problema más
urgente que enfrenta el país es la
elevada inflación más detalles en el
informe
[Aplausos]
ante miles de Seguidores eufóricos
celebró su Victoria en el Palacio
presidencial se queda para un tercer
mandato
[Música]
nuestra nación nos ha confiado de nuevo
esta misión por un período de 5 años
debemos centrarnos en nuestros sueños
como nación en nuestras ambiciones y
unirnos
fue también desde ankara que su
contrincante quema alquililla tomó la
palabra para admitir su derrota
el pueblo expresó su voluntad de
rechazar una forma de autocracia pero no
fue suficiente lo que me entristece son
las grandes dificultades que tiene
Turquía por delante
está selecciones ponen fin a semanas de
campaña muy polarizada una parte del
electorado soñaba con el cambio una
población hastiada de la crisis
económica del hundimiento de la lira
turca y la concentración del poder en la
presidencia pero para hacer frente a los
desafíos la mayoría ha elegido otro
camino el de la estabilidad no es solo
el líder de Turquía sino que recepta
Jeep erdoan es un líder mundial nuestro
único líder nuestro único guía surgieron
concentraciones espontáneas en varias
ciudades turcas incluso aquí en
gaciantepec en esta ciudad azotada por
el Terrible terremoto del pasado febrero
la confianza entre aduana no ha
flaqueado
cambiamos de tema porque en Estados
Unidos este domingo el presidente Joe
biden anunció que en conjunto con el
líder de la cámara de representantes el
republicano Kevin mccarthy llegaron a un
acuerdo bipartidista para Elevar el
techo de la deuda y evitar la catástrofe
que significaría entrar en impago byden
hizo un llamado al congreso para probar
el texto algo que debe lograrse antes
del 5 de junio Ramiro cueva Barberena
nos amplía
tras una ardua negociación el presidente
Joe biden y el líder republicano del
Congreso Kevin mccarthy llegaron a un
acuerdo para aumentar el techo de la
deuda suspendiendo la Barrera actual de
31,4 billones de dólares hasta después
de las elecciones de 2024
Creo que este es un acuerdo en principio
digno del pueblo estadounidense contiene
reducciones históricas del gasto
reformas importantes que sacarán a la
gente de la pobreza y la incorporarán al
mercado laboral controlarán las
extralimitaciones del gobierno no hay
nuevos impuestos en ni nuevos programas
gubernamentales y hay mucho más en el
proyecto de ley Este es un tema central
porque significa que se gobierno no
puede endeudarse no contará con fondos
para afrontar sus compromisos afectando
el funcionamiento interno como los pagos
de la seguridad social prestaciones a
los veteranos y los empleados públicos
pero también generaría una crisis
internacional impactando en los mercados
financieros mundiales
hemos alcanzado un acuerdo de
presupuesto bipartidista y está listo
para pasar al pleno del Congreso creo
que es un importante paso hacia adelante
que quita el catastrófico cese de pagos
de la mesa protege nuestra frontera y
empieza la recuperación de nuestra
economía aunque los detalles aún no se
han hecho públicos limitaría el gasto
protegería el presupuesto de defensa y
endurecería algunos requisitos para
acceder a las ayudas públicas el
proyecto de ley se votará el miércoles
en la cámara de representantes para
iniciar el proceso de aprobación esto
debe suceder antes de la fecha límite
del 5 de junio cuando se supone que se
agota el dinero del tesoro vamos a
México porque miles de ciudadanos se
manifestaron en la capital y en otras
ciudades del país a favor de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia los manifestantes
corearon consignas como la corte no se
toca según los ciudadanos hay una
campaña de hostigamiento al poder
judicial y a suministra presidenta Norma
Lucía piña por parte del presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador y sus
seguidores en varias ocasiones han
acusado de los jueces del alto tribunal
de corruptos por los fallos en contra de
la llamada cuarta transformación que
impulsa el jefe de estado los detalles
con Mario carbonel corresponsal de
France 24 en Ciudad de México
miles de ciudadanos respondieron este
domingo al llamado de algunas
organizaciones sociales entre ellas
chalecos México a marchar en distintas
ciudades del país y aquí en la capital
de la república para defender a la
suprema corte de justicia de la nación y
a su presidenta la ministra norma piña
de las constantes y fuertes críticas del
presidente López Obrador y los
seguidores de su partido Morena
se movilizaron desde el Monumento a la
Revolución hasta el Zócalo y ya una vez
en las inmediaciones de la Sede del
poder judicial se registró un conato de
enfrentamiento entre quienes marchaban y
quienes permanecían desde hace más de un
mes en plantón a las puertas de la corte
para exigir la renuncia de los ministros
por considerar los corruptos tuvo que
intervenir personal de la Secretaría de
Seguridad Ciudadana para impedir que
este enfrentamiento llegara a mayores
esta situación se da Después de semanas
que el presidente López Obrador en sus
conferencias matutinas a dirigido
críticas
al poder judicial luego de los fallos
que ha emitido este en contra de algunas
medidas de gobierno por ejemplo que han
tumbado el Plan B electoral o
recientemente han echado abajo un
decreto mediante el cual el gobierno
pretendía que las obras públicas de
gobierno fueran consideradas de
seguridad nacional y por tanto que da la
reservada la información a raíz de estos
fallos de los ministros López Obrador ha
considerado que el poder judicial está
podrido que los ministros responden a
los intereses de una minoría rapaz y que
son una banda de conservadores por tanto
ha dicho que va a reformar o va a meter
una iniciativa para reformar al poder
judicial y que los ministros sean
electos por vía del voto popular quienes
cuestionan estas medidas del presidente
consideran que lo único que busca el
mandatario es tener una corte a modo
controlada y que no objete sus medidas
de gobierno
chile maestros de boxeo tailandés
dictaron un taller de autodefensa
destinado a la comunidad lgbtiq más el
objetivo era enseñarles herramientas
para poder protegerse de los delitos de
odio cuyas cifras están en aumento en el
país latinoamericano
Cómo proteger su rostro y dónde golpear
a un agresor para neutralizarlo 50
miembros de la comunidad lgbtiq más
chilena escucharon los consejos de esos
tres campeones de muay thai el boxeo
tailandés participaron en este taller
gratuito de defensa personal para
aprender a reaccionar cuando son
Víctimas de agresiones por ejemplo
es difícil así como es mejor tener algo
por lo que recibir ese momento en 2022
los crímenes de odio contra las personas
lgbtiq más se duplicaron En comparación
con 2021 o incluso seis homicidios las
cifra más alta registrada para Ignacio
esta actividad también puede servirle
para su vida diaria en el marco del
aumento de La criminalidad callejera en
Chile a mí me da un poco de miedo andar
en la calle así como en la noche o cosas
así porque
puede pasar cualquier cosa y es súper
bueno que integren esto a personas
sobre todo porque es lo que más lo
necesitan según el último informe anual
de derechos humanos de la diversidad
sexual y de género en Chile el año
pasado se registraron más de mil casos
de discriminación en cuanto al muay es
el deporte nacional de Tailandia y desde
2021 fue como de categoría olímpica por
esa razón en unos próximos juegos podría
estar presente en la competencia
la UNESCO inscribió como patrimonio
documental de la humanidad el cartel de
cine cubano para el organismo el
programa permite la conservación del
patrimonio audiovisual que es también
memoria colectiva del mundo la directora
de la oficina de la UNESCO para la
región destacó que hay una gran
originalidad creativa en los carteles
que se une a la belleza gráfica y a la
eficacia comunicativa la categoría de
registro fue creada
1992 y abarca 430 obras patrimoniales
que incluyen piezas audiovisuales y
manuscritos
con estas imágenes llegamos al final de
informativo gracias por su sintonía
[Música]